[Music]
and not worth it news messing up in here
especially for you it's not with oh no
as I'm gonna do it animals submitted by
a shot bowl of pho oh that's nourishes
mmm with the thumb in a bowl when I
serve it to you oh yeah a family is
having a hard time finding a nanny for
their haunted house not worth it not for
Facebook that I'll be homeless with no
food in my belly
do you believe in haunted things I don't
disbelief I've never witnessed it and I
hope I never do you know what homes are
well I'm kind of Hana no no no don't
tell me do I ever am I ever gonna go
back there okay Thomas the Malibu house
ruined well at least the room that I was
in I would keep building like a
silhouette or a shadow a little Lily
with that okay I'm like well what is
that
look I dismissed me whether the seagulls
know it wasn't called silhouette it
would be like like I would like my would
say I'm taking a shower I come out of
the shower and I would just feel like oh
my god out of the corner I'm crazy yeah
I was kind of weird it feels like way
back when because Katie said that the
room he was saying in seemed like like a
like a house keepers quarters yeah it is
up there's a room upstairs
it looks like an orphanage there's like
a ton of little twin sized beds
everywhere oh my god you know what that
spirit was what me [ __ ] watching you
this was my shield do some [ __ ]
come on keep on tripping my aura grab
your jacket off ah I'm getting a jackoff
yeah that's not your mean I was jacking
off into the ocean Isabella's fog is
adding salt we all the bumper needs that
look at a wave guys we can't do this
really on hold there to make the [ __ ]
cares like next week
into the ocean and those kind of wash it
away
hey it's food fish food you said just
like part it's for the sperm where the
birds though it's for the sperm whales
birds don't eat come you are so weird
sardines on the other hand wait so how
has been the conversation oh no I think
you'd really like a man come oh god
that's so good okay so um the list so
there's is limping for a living Manny
oh they got to live there too yeah okay
I'm down with that so they're looking
for a nanny because they're saying that
the past five nannies have left
in the last year oh [ __ ] citing
supernatural incidents there's not a
ghost it's a [ __ ] shitty family that's
what it is
well this is what they're saying the
reasons are strange noises broken glass
and furniture movies are there kids like
you to me you have two kids
yeah oh no a bunch of kids to me ages
five and seven yeah I beat their ass
they're [ __ ] pranking her yeah for
sure like Dennis the Menace's I'll be
I'll be a nanny
yeah watch the ghost go away [ __ ]
beat those kids every day you [ __ ]
try to [ __ ] with me [ __ ] or is
their house near like a park I'm not
sure not to do it no no no explain that
to you don't exercise you just lost all
of us work oh my gosh okay so based on
two people that I know because like they
actually have encounters with spirits
and I move back and you know the
weirdest [ __ ] well see you if
you have to like this has to be said so
after she's yeah I know what she has to
say you know the wonderful spot tell us
about the two people that represent the
entire world that live mr. Park oh no
also one of the live next to apart but
then the other one can actually like
physically see the spirits and it seems
like a lot of spirits do collect at the
park especially at nighttime I don't
very exactly what the reason is but like
apparently does like a lot of kids that
are like playing around in that Park
area like especially at night they all
come together you know what the funniest
thing about the story is is the fact
that you expected us to know this your
site is at a park but like the next
thought what are the different dead
spirits around it
I thought that's our one laughing lovely
yeah I thought I thought it was like oh
they're next to a park because there's
noise yeah well I'll be like I play
baseball that align that to a part why
experi there all the time because my mom
does Mira like a junior high or
something and you know there's always
kids playing do we live next to the
[ __ ] cemetery and there's no [ __ ]
happening and I bet they all kick it to
her I live next to a cemetery for a long
time but I was protected because Bart's
grandpa and stuff is there and a couple
of my friends and eazy-e so it
gravitated there was easy I lived in a
house that was right behind on a
cemetery a few years ago I think I was
there for like three years but that
place I was trying so hard to not
believe in like the spirits or anything
like that but there was just so many
times where I kept seeing so right
outside my window is one time I could
clearly remember I was on the phone
Halloween over by I don't want to hear
this [ __ ] it's really short so I was on
the phone and I care how long it is it
sounds scary listen to it and so I was
looking outside on the street because it
was like this car that passed by and
then oh no you know what
I remember now clearly sorry haha so I
was outside I was outside right because
I was talking with my boyfriend in the
middle of night I wasn't supposed to be
using the phone so I went outside I look
on the floor as I'm speaking I see this
shadow passing that like it was it
looked like someone was on the roof
because it was like a human shadow that
passed by and I looked up quickly I
didn't see anybody I didn't hear
anything either and then I quickly
jumped on top of a fence to see over the
roof and there was nobody it was like
cold so that was one another one was
where I was I fell asleep in the living
room smells on a lazy boy so it's like a
really fat check but it's swiveled so I
ended up sleeping like with my back
against the TV and the TV turn on a
melon I like what the [ __ ] I probably
found the remote control I turned it off
and then that entire living room has
like wooden it was like wooden floor so
I kept hearing these creeks right by
where I was sitting
so I'm like that's [ __ ] freaky yeah
what the thing is though man how would
you say this in one on the roof well we
could be ghosts right it's like if you
know like their existence is true right
are you just going on TV no do something
more extravagant to me that's all I was
trying to tell myself to but I thought
that I'm not saying I don't believe in
ghosts I'm just saying give me some real
proof
yeah like I don't go yeah there's
something else hey hey what's up John
been watching you okay now there's a
[ __ ] ghost for real don't give me
these clues like what if that's all they
can do I did I'm glad but I think that's
because they're scared of me because
they know if I fart I'll [ __ ] kill
them no transcend to the soprano world
or [ __ ] or that you just have like a
really hot body and then what I mean by
that is I do I think so because my idea
you were going to say that my friend has
like shoot so she says I have like very
hot body so that's why I don't know I
just get attracted to her but if you
have a cold body you got the hot and
cold of Chinese culture like that's a
part of Taoism or what is it the hot and
cold your your mom believes in that yeah
what is it is it I just I just picture a
bunch of ghosts sweating their asses off
next to you [ __ ] you there must
be a whole bunch of ghosts around you
because you called it
wait so you're saying hot buddies
they're not attracted to these they are
yeah like they'll be more energy I think
it's oh it's Qi Gong I think it's called
Qi Gong or something or something like
that but it's about so Chinese people
believe in this Qi energy and also
there's Qi energy in foods and other
things also things are hot and cold for
me I guess I didn't have enough from I
mean like I but I take it as pH so
there's there's food with high pH as
acidic or basic or whatever but they
have the same concept like oh these
foods are cold cold these foods are hot
whatever but then they also say like
some people's energies they just have
hot body temperature cold body
temperature energies are different so
I'm like okay that's not like the
Eastern medicine doctors they'll
prescribe certain meals and food for you
right for like hot and cold night oh
yeah hot so you need to have this clamps
or sometimes a measure if your heart
doctors will look at your eyeball do not
bad it's gonna go like this - they like
fill your pulse and they can feel
different parts of your kidney there's
hot and cold and then it also breaks
down into like if they're more of a wood
person more of a water person more of a
dirt person more like a metal person
that's basically what Julie is talking
about about the hot and cold and how
that energy can bring in ghosts or not
bringing ghost you can explain these
things so there's a lot of people that
don't understand this [ __ ] and that's
how your friends sound Crazy's brother
yeah and you gas issue but a lot of
people in Asia believe this though I
just don't want to think about ghosts in
my mind if I don't think about that
they're not gonna affect me too
I'm saying and so it's not the fact I
don't believe that ghosts exist it's the
matter of fact I just don't want to
think about me - I just feel like when I
die I have a whole lot of time to deal
with it then but right now I'm worried
about what's important right now and
there's a lot more interesting things
like catching up with all my Netflix
shows that's pretty much you know I mean
this is like small things - it's like
though if I mean for a ghost interest it
doesn't matter trying to kill anybody
you wear it sometimes into the search
area yeah like if they're going to start
a skin
annoying me every day after a while it
was set in reality it's like okay you're
just gonna piss me off every day that's
cool you just wait till I [ __ ] die
dude I will [ __ ] your ass I'm just
kiddin ya I say I will [ __ ] you up
like after wat life it becomes like such
a fact that ghosts exist and all they're
doing is just to annoy you every day I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up when I'm a ghost
straight up well I guess if you guys
believe in the whole ghost thing that
you guys also believe in the demon thing
too because of all that stuff cuz
they're saying that like all these like
poltergeist things with demons trying to
get like the humans really afraid and
vulnerable and then that's what makes go
in and I don't know all men of a demon
takes over my bodies would be very
disappointed [ __ ] I got it whose [ __ ]
ankles don't work his knees don't work I
don't need no demon already got anger
problems
[ __ ] that already have a demon right
yeah I don't need any more people just
try to leave you and I like this all I
can't stay in this body it's too crazy
you guys wouldn't be down to take up
this job if I meet a hug all day not
worth it depends on the money yeah cuz
you get 28 days vacation I don't give up
I don't believe in go so I take it on
and then I would just view or care when
you sell someone in the corner no cuz
imma show your face [ __ ]
and that's where this went away you said
that out loud on my mind I use my ghost
talk and I'll show your face
[ __ ] really want to [ __ ] with
me Barnes just gonna get some incense
and burn some Chinese money and it's
going to be cool
yeah like though I bet you that goes
cameras right wait I know who's mommies
don't [ __ ] with it mom are we talking
about ghosts just don't [ __ ] with my son
I told you already Peter hello everybody
if you like the video make sure that you
guys leave us a thumbs up because if not
I'm gonna find you where you live and
I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you with
you I got other than that you know
there's like more videos up there from
you
[Music]